hey guys Anna and David Roseanne's
kitchen table and as the year wraps up
we want to tell you about our personal
best and worst moments of the year so
I'm gonna let you go first on this one
you want to start good or good or bad
let's start with bad all right let's do
it
start with bad Co all right I would say
my worst moment I'm gonna do to the
worst moments career-wise was when we
actually reported on an email that was
obtained through the Sony hack
that was really classless on my part and
I felt really bad about it after we did
it I don't know why I chose to do that
story it was such an invasion of privacy
and so you know professionally I think
that was my worst moment yeah now you
did correct that because you took the
video down what was it up even 24 hours
I'm not sure how long it was up to be
honest with you because I never keep
track of that kind of stuff but it was
up you know it was public and people saw
it and we fed into that terrible
terrible situation and so I regretted it
and when I do something wrong I will
admit it and I was what cause you was it
like right because sometimes when we're
talking on camera like you start saying
things and then you realize that you're
sort of regretting or you're gonna
regret what you're saying when the
segment duck was done were you like
that's the moment or did it yeah it took
a while and I want to thank I don't
remember your handle on Twitter but
there was someone who tweeted to me and
he made a really great point he said if
you're so against the celebrity nude
back then why is it okay for you to be
in favor of the Sony hack and then leak
or report what was obtained through that
hack and I was like you know what this
person is 100% right and I'm an idiot
that was a huge lapse of judgment so
that was not a shining moment for me and
you know what real quick you know we
were talking about the NSA before in
this whole privacy thing and everything
else and it's like if any of us want any
degree of privacy if we're gonna if
someone's gonna hack into Sony and then
we're gonna talk about their emails or
share their pictures or whatever it is
well then we have no right if someone
was to hack into your personal email and
spread it all over you would have no
right to not be upset by that absolutely
yeah so there you go so that was that's
one for you and so the other thing is
personal I would say another bad moment
in this year was the decision to join
tinder tinder I'm terrible no one's
I don't even know if it's like a popular
dating app anymore but I met some of the
scummiest people through tinder and you
are going crazy when you were on tinder
like there was like a month where you
were on there and first up you never
picked up your head because you were
just swiping constantly you develop that
horrible carpal tunnel yeah and just
telling me about all these guys over and
over yeah yeah I kind of went nuts
because for the first time I was single
like seven years I was like yeah I'm
gonna go out on these dates and it's
gonna be freakin awesome and then you go
out on all these dates and you realize
what's out there and I don't think that
tinder is an accurate representation of
the guys out there right I think that it
attracts a certain demographic right but
it was every guy there just want to have
sex at the end of the day no it was the
opposite issue with me I mean every time
I met some guy that I was actually
really interested in he was like too
timid and afraid to make a move and I
was like what is up with you I don't
understand no believe it or not a lot of
the guys on tinder were pretty
respectful toward me I didn't really get
a lot of negative messages or anything
like that it was just when I went out on
dates and I realized that there was a
lack of ambition among a lot of people
okay and that's not to say that like oh
he doesn't have a job he's a loser
that's not the case it was just a lack
of goals ambition
you know I need fire and none of them
had that goals and ambition right here
for me we talked about this on the point
a couple weeks ago my worst moment of
the year is that a friend of mine who
was a good friend when we were much
younger but then our families are very
close and I stayed in contact with him
over these last couple years basically
had a drug problem was in and out of
rehab kind of thing and and he ended up
dying this year and my my so my regret
so the worst moment was him him dying
but my regret as I told you on the point
was that I didn't do more I don't know
what I could have done I lived 3,000
miles away from him we didn't have that
great contact but in the course of the
last couple years where maybe there were
moments that I could have could have
done something I don't even know that
that's like a real thing but just that
feeling of like you know someone that
you know so closely you know dying
somewhat related to drugs and all that
like it just brings up a lot of stuff I
think that was yeah I mean
that's in hard and I have a really good
friend whose brother is addicted to a
lot of hard drugs and the unfortunate
thing is there's really nothing you can
do they have to yeah you know want help
in order for the habit to change alright
well so from that to our best moments
give me something good I'm glad that we
started with the bad so let's end on a
good well play again yeah so I would say
I had a lot of great moments this year
you know I reflect back on a trip that I
took with my friend to Spain and I got
to experience the culture and the
wonderful people I went to France with
Genki ogre host of The Young Turks for
media conference and I got to bond with
him
in an you know different setting which
was nice I taught another journalism
class I frickin love that but I would
say the highlight of this year was a
conversation I had with you that I'll
never forget and it was after our I had
been single for a while I'd been on a
bunch of really bad dates and I was
getting kind of depressed because I
thought I was going to be alone forever
which is a ridiculous thing to think for
anyone and then Dave is like you're not
gonna be alone forever okay but let's
say that that does happen okay look at
your life your life is so full and I
hadn't even realized it until you said
it and you mentioned like the friends
that I have the family that I have the
job that I have and all these like busy
moments and how not having a
relationship isn't the end of the world
and that really taught me something that
was basically the start of me really
appreciating solitude and being alone
and being comfortable with you know
being a single person yeah yeah well
first off I just want to say that I do
not set Anna up to say that I'm old I'm
almost as good as Reese Witherspoon you
like why do I say Reese Witherspoon
Reese Witherspoon earlier will annotate
back to that well thank you that's
really nice to hear and but he that's
the thing actually because I remember I
know exactly where we were we were on La
Cienega like right before the Beverly
Center and you were going on and on and
I was looking at you just thinking like
what is she talking about it was so
obvious to me like actually what the
truth was and you just needed like a
little I needed someone to kind of slap
me in the face with the truth and that's
what
in a very polite way yeah pretty good
also my best moment clearly that thing
right there
yeah like it was it was a long time I've
been in my boyfriend for about four
years or so I never really thought about
it but actually I can even figure out
what linking this to one conversation
that we had where we went out for brunch
one day and you kind of asked me
something about it and I had a few
conversations over the last like six
months with some good friends where
people were just like are you gonna do
it all right like it became obvious to
them and then what it made me realize
was it would say more about me if I
didn't do it like we're great I don't
think you know like I don't even think
the paper necessarily and all that
traditional stuff is that important like
we live a good life it's all good but
when it started becoming obvious to
other people my uncle who never talked
to me about relationships or anything
was like are you gonna do it yep then a
few other people then it was just like
oh like after and that's sort of that
ironically I think is why gay marriage
is so important because if you want
people because first off everyone should
just be equal
that's just goes without saying but um
you want people's lives to like be able
to mature and like keep moving forward
in everything I can see it already just
in a couple weeks of this like my life's
gonna go into a new phase so like that
that definitely was a positive I love
that you guys got engaged and the story
was super sweet and and you get to
benefit from a lot of his cooking
because not only is cooking okay the
person who is the EP of this show is
also the EP of the point and he is the
best
okay David Janet you are the bomb he's
sitting right over here we're not gonna
show up very humble and good decent
person not like these two ego maniacs
right here what was your what was your
best moment of 2014 what was your worst
moment of 2014
let us know in the comments right down
below